hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the fall
i'm interrupting this video to bring you
a very special message this video is
brought to you by epic games because
i am now an epic partner and you can
support me
by using my creator code markiplier on
the epic game store
if you want to check out this game for
yourself there's a link down the
description
okay bye or back to your regularly
scheduled
programming we are about to discover
what it means to be a robot
just from looking at the trailer of this
i'm assuming we're gonna find out
exactly why
the ais that we build are going to rebel
against us i'm pretty sure
that that's what this game is about oh
hi
oh hi
[Music]
handyman shield enabled oh okay
oh
good we were actually falling i thought
that was some kind of a dream sequence
or something
okay oh
i get it yeah minor landing damage
sustained
uh health monitoring systems offline so
the reason that i was drawn to this game
inoperable pilot unresponsive life
support
functioning basic mark 7 system access
routed to a
r i d a i primary objective
save my pilot am i your pilot
yeah i mean on suit logs mission
parameters and location data not found
what oh okay here we go
oh i'm packing
bam boom ah damn it oh
the tunnel created from my impact i can
see stars in the distance i am
approximately 50 meters below the
surface
okay so what drew me to this game is it
kind of reminded me of um
uh you know inside it but more
specifically the other one or the one
that came before it
oh god elixie and put footage of me
playing it oh hello there
hi hi how's it going what are you doing
huh
limbo is it limbo limbo limbo limbo
limbo limbo
limbo limbo but it's obviously not like
that
in terms of story the story is uh
somehow even darker
okay so there's one spot there oh here
we go
a trail of blood and broken glass
something was dragged through here
weapon rendered inoperable from the
impact consulting parameters
i will locate medical facilities okay
explore to progress many hints in the
fall are hidden in data notes like
these two if you're not sure where to go
explore and read oh
we gotta explore and read
where's all the shoot bangy boom coming
in
oh hey grabby hand how you doing oh it's
the iron giant
hey a large pile of damaged and
destroyed synthetics
some of these power systems are still
giving off minute electrical signals
yeah like the eyeballs the oh god
if i was a some kind of a robo this
would be horrifying
[Music]
ah i don't know what that was a robotic
arm
the gripping mechanism is still operable
is about does it go grab me
better not grab me a damaged control
panel for an old garbage chute there
must be another cavern below this one
perhaps there's another way down but why
would i want to go down
i don't know if down is what i want to
do
a micro wrench what does that mean you
mean a wrench
is that is that is that suggestive that
there's a macro wrench okay
oh oh okay network i'm gonna network
with this thing
network interface disabled okay i'm not
gonna network with this thing i'm gonna
interact
this may be useful
okay i don't have my gun anymore i feel
i feel pretty naked without that can i
okay good
i'm i may not be uh actually packing
heat but i
i like having it out it makes me feel
better okay
this cloaking pattern is similar to my
own i may be able to network it
you know if i saw a dude crucified in
the middle of an
underground cavern that i just so
happened to crash land into
i wouldn't be thinking about the fact
that there is a cloaking pattern
that conveniently censors it okay i'm
gonna
network ah network interface design
require access to my networking suite
attempting internal activation
okay press escape to check your
operating portion also the fact that
this dude is still bleeding
suggests that this might have been very
recent some kind of freak accident
now i came down here and i crashed and
this guy just so happened to slam up
against
something that just so happened to form
a cross
either way i'm uncomfortable
must not misrepresent reality must be
obedient must protect active pilot oh
operating stream welcome to the
operating screen here you can check the
status of your different abilities
okay is there some dude in am i the suit
and there's some dude inside is that
what i'm
picking up from this is that what i'm
understanding and he may not be doing so
good
an organic superior officer is required
to permit access
automatic override will occur if this
subsystem is required to prevent pilot
death well he might
be close to pilot death subsystem access
requires authorization
but i may need these systems to
safeguard my pilot
find a way to bypass the lockout i could
override the access protocols myself
yeah okay all right why is this so
goddamn creepy
let's see and hit him with a jump scare
i'm just getting ahead of it so that i
don't get spooked
all right i'm gonna just that doesn't
look good the security panel is
it is its power cell has been burned out
okay can i
i can't network with that definitely not
oh
micro wrench that does not work so
that's definitely a problem
a motion sensor it's blocking access to
the elevator i'm guessing if i step in
this
an unpowered center gun is likely
connected to the security panel
okay all right but that's fine an
abandoned security card
i can fit my hand through the bars but
still cannot reach scoop it with your
gun
kind of flange it all right whatever
fine
i'll just mosey on back then so there's
got to be something else
that i have missed maybe something in
here
huh what about you grabby
microwrench yes grabby oh i can grab
the security card don't mind if i do
or i should be able to control the grasp
yes
i'm going to firmly grasp it this
reminds me of like out of this world you
know what i mean
[Music]
robotic arm nice
yeah we are living in the future i guess
what do i do with this card
i'm guessing i look at this oh but no
power cell right
okay i need a power cell maybe there's a
power cell somewhere in one of the
the piles it said the power was still
flickering so there there might actually
be some
power still left in here
i cannot that does not work
okay maybe there's something back in the
beginning that i missed
who small bioluminescent
insects well ain't that adorable
hey oh
okay oh it does not require a key
oh all right then use
oh boy this can only be good
this can only be really really good
oh
it's fine old metal pan empty and
relatively clean do i need that
i do what is this
security card and a pan
okay
oh that's oh i don't like this please
oh hi artificial life form
state your primary function uh
acquire data negative reveal your
designation
and intention you are being evaluated
for purposing
state your primary function uh
deny access negative i will not reveal
my directives to an
unknown entity infraction avoidance
continued infractions will result in
failure do not
attempt de-purposing hostility will
result in full defensive engagement
irrelevant state your primary function
hmm
unlock the door i am leaving negative
all artificial life forms must comply
state your primary function
all right fine you talked it out of me
my primary function is to assist and
protect the human pilot of this armored
combat suit
human occupant please verify and
validate the function of this artificial
life form
impossible he is unresponsive and likely
in critical condition
i must find him medical treatment
immediately can you be of assistance
evaluation failed unit unable to
demonstrate
valid primary function i'm about to
visualize
i'm about to
oh boy oh god
well convenient okay wait oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh you
you want some neural you want some
neural take some of this neural
okay oh i i'm okay
i'm going to network oh
wow what the hell was that i'm
not gonna lie pretty badass not gonna
lie pretty badass
if i do say so myself you ain't gonna
touch my pilot my pilot protected
100 100
and now i got the the evaluation
initiated
exposed to harm while under arid control
logging recommendations from arid
diagnostic and reformatting upon return
to dock
ultimately pilot was not harmed in arid
networking suite was brought online
this system may be instrumental to
ensuring survival
glad i just changed my mind unless i'm
the pilot
in this scenario and i'm just dreaming
all of this up which is entirely
possible
hey later dudes i gotta go interface
with a uh
oh hey i thought you were gone
all right uh internet interface oh
please identify yourself and your
intentions like
endpoints are inoperable i am the arid
unborn mark 7 combat suit my intentions
are peaceful does your pilot require
assistance
the human inside the suit is dead hey
my pilot is injured are you aware of
on-site medical facilities
negative we were not here long enough to
complete our surgery
there was a large compound above this
cavern it has amenities for humans and
machines
so basically medical scanners and
equipment would be logical
a motion sensor prohibits access to the
facility above
do you know how to bypass it use your
integrated camouflage
i have integrated camouflage
[Music]
okay all right your design is
pilot-centric how did this human die
in your care i was granted rudimentary
control when my pilot's cranium was
compromised i do not know why she was
attacked
or why we were hung here i failed to
protect her
no vital signs detected for 23 minutes
she is dead you are irrelevant i will
find a way to get you down
then i will deactivate you and repurpose
your power cell
affirmative
brutal i encountered a modified droid in
some type of evaluation chamber
i am uncertain if its function is
hostile or narrowly programmed do you
know why it interrogated me
negative you were not interrogated have
you encountered
any organics the indigenous flora and
fauna
are aggressive closer to the surface the
only organic i have encountered here
is animal who took my sidearm okay well
that answers the question about the gun
functional mine was damaged it was my
pilot's attacker threw it aside while
hanging us here before my observational
system expired
i saw a small animal dragon through a
crack in the floor
it may still be functioning if there is
another cavern below us
i may be able to retrieve the trash
shoot i will return
i may not uh you got oh the
the pan the pan
that's how i have the pan i require only
a few
drops please a few drippy drips of blood
this blood should look all right so
let's see if we can go
down i can probably network with this
now
ah perhaps there's another way down
yeah perhaps
oh i know i know
i have another idea that's even more
genius oh
[Music]
network ah can i
hit it and run run run
okay i go down it's fine
it's fine oh yeah this is good you know
for an all-powerful robot i sure do get
the heebie-jeebies out of this place
well clearly not all powerful but pretty
close you know better than those
squooshy humos
this cavern has been filled with a
massive quantity of dissected and
discarded robots
great i like that okay
any place where i could put a pan full
of blood that i have not suspiciously
obtained
it's all on the up and up all within my
mission parameters that i
definitely remember the most recent
model i detect is decades old other than
where some of these machines
show no sign of malfunction yeah
bits of bone and animal dropping well
that seems like a great place for a pan
full of blood
great place hair the animal is timid
it will not exit the borough while i am
in proximity i mean i would have guessed
that too but i thought my whistling was
doing on
doing something for it but okay whoa i
hear that
what i didn't know i could do that oh
damn look at me god damn
all right uh now the question is how do
i get the weapon out of him
right so screaming at it didn't work
lexi and just cut all around this so it
makes it look like i figured it out
right off the bat you know what i mean
you know what i'm saying man if i could
interface with the gun and
get it to go off it would solve my
problem maybe that's
is that what i do
oh oh no
oh no
i'm so smart oh no
oh i'm sorry oh
no his weapon is still honorable
bang oh
what was that what was that up and take
the wilder charge be careful
oh no what was that you said about
the the mumbly bumblies i didn't like
all the mumbly bumblies
oh
shut down all systems immediately or you
will be destroyed
ah hey how's it going
on board this mark 7 combat suit my
intentions are peaceful what is your
target not complying
red novel escalated engaging okay
oh good thing i knew about that several
enemies in the fall are much more
powerful than you
why oh yeah ah try me is stupid
i'll never come out of cover
trick job
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
okay oh
god damn this this this soundtrack oh
you'll never get me oh right in the dick
you like that did you like that
jump oh
oh for some reason my shield is down why
didn't i shield them
all right hey dude uh get ready to be
decommissioned
you failed your primary objective
whatever that was
oh if you approach an enemy without
being seen you can perform a takedown
aaron will salvage some of the enemy's
energy to oh
can i crouch i cannot i wish i could
turn this lamp off my face
can i do something about this
thanks for the power nerd
[Laughter]
seeing everybody can i shoot this thing
no bam boom
bam what am i supposed to do now i
thought i'd go
get the gun and now i have the gun
and now i use the gun let's see and cut
ahead until i'm smart again
oh oh what if i shoot that oh
there we go oh you're down baby yeah
thank goodness i got that on the first
try lick cna thanks for uh
being such a great editor and not
telling anybody of any secret things
that we uh don't talk about
thanks pal okay i can remove the power
cell now i will do that
identify yourself and your intent my
inputs are
i am the arid on bottom mark 7 combat
suit
i have returned what's your pilot like
confirmed your pilot is dead you serve
no function
okay love
is still operational i will deactivate
you and salvage it
affirmative return it with my law corps
for analysis and data extraction
negative protecting my pilot requires
endangerment
i will utilize your power style to
achieve this impossible you are faulty
cease cease
uh yep
it's mine now uh sorry about that uh
let me just plop that bad boy in there
security gun has been reactivated
and i'm guessing that that's gonna shoot
me now and i'm gonna cloak
you're right
i can change
excellent i am secret now
oh i see i see i see i see all
okay watch this ah no no you don't see a
thing
you don't see a thing dude watch this
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm a genius i'm smart i'm free
good game everybody good game but i am
out of here and we are moving on with
hey hi bud
you okay just a funny prank that we
pulled on each other
funny hilarious i have directly violated
operating parameters by placing my pilot
in mortal danger logging recommendation
for ar
id termination upon return to doc
but also parameters were not violated
infraction enabled access to systems
that safeguard
pilot search parameters maintained
find immediate medical aid that's a good
point
how about the weird creepy music okay
yeah
oh boy deep purposing this appears to be
the lowest level of a larger facility
yeah yeah it seems like a lot of
de-purposing happen
and i don't like this here
oh this seems like combat
click no i must resist
oh camouflage oh
you thought you thought and dodge
oh idiot oh shadow i shoot
i missed oh god damn it no
all right that went poorly oh god
aha
oh i will destroy you
i will destroy you and destroy you i
will yes
mine thank you this game is kind of cool
i like it oh what are you looking at
nothing deal weed you want some of this
i bet if i shoot you it won't do nothing
cause you're behind glass or something
like that
okay on powered security terminal
there's a button marked
diagnostics but the interface is unknown
to me
all right i can't interface with any of
this
i will go this way to save my pilot
no matter what simple panel with a
speaker a microphone and a number pad
all right weird working together today
for a more efficient tomorrow to record
employment hours or long breaks
press one press two for human assistance
remember
our droids are versatile and can aid
with many tasks for all other inquiries
press three press four to repeat these
options if this is an emergency
press five for facility lockdown oh
this button has been pried out and the
mechanism has been soldered that's kind
of crap certainty equals quality
how may i assist you i am the arid
on bottom mark 7 combat suit my
intentions
are peaceful i require immediate medical
assistance
for my pilot
oops i'm sorry please repeat hey this
seems familiar
welcome hi hi hello
wow wow wow this is great i
who are you what are you sweet
sweet is this a human operator of the
facility
i require assistance i am the arid on
bottom mark 7 combat suit my intentions
are peaceful greetings this is the
automated system administrator
how can human oh that's that's swell of
you but no
i can't believe it someone to interface
with
amazing processing mark 7 a r i d
designation an armored robotic interface
device right
cool i never worked with a mark four
once
combat suit aren't you what are you
doing here
uh my pilot has been
uh since my activation at impact i seek
medical aid for him
are you able to assist us no problem
eric
can i call you eric you know i haven't
picked a name for myself yet
was thinking maybe hank or morally
but the medical facilities i don't like
this guy
right right i'll just put your quantum
signature on file
and now you can head right through the
testing area there's a basic medical
room off the lobby
equipped with scanners and diagnostics
for garments administrators
oh no consorting to release a deviant
machine from the facility
is an infraction desist immediately
deviant
this arid mark 7 violates its model's
protocols it imperiled its pilot to
bypass an internal
system lock it is faulty uh droid in
question
is this accusation true i'm sure it's a
misunderstanding
right arid right oh i cannot lie
i cannot tell a lie this infraction
granted me access to fundamental
protections
it was necessary to ensure my pilot's
safety droid in question
you have been qualified for
recalibration you have no rights until
proven to function within specification
domesticcon is not equipped to validate
a military-grade droid
the deviant mark vii ar id will be
de-purposed oh what is with you
wait when a product now functions or
becomes outdated try to recycle by
calibrating it for a simpler task
such repurposed machines are ideal for
fulfilling warranties
if she can be refurbished as a domestic
droid it would be wasteful to discard
her
that is sensible a domestic
what what are we commenting i did not
consent to any of this i have
re-uploaded your quantum signature
military machine no more you are eric
the faulty domestic droid you want me to
undergo evaluation as a domestic droid
i do not have the requisite subroutines
why did that droid agree to this and why
has your monitor lost symmetry
that's my face you're gonna do fine
don't be paranoid
the medical you needs just on the other
side waiting for you to be validated
just follow the rules i don't uh
oh no i will not i am the arid
on board a mark 7 combat suit my
intentions are peaceful
you do not have jurisdiction over
infraction subject not complying
security droid activated watch out push
out
why oh hey uh oh uh uh nope
take some of this oh god oh god oh
no
uh okay so that was a terrible idea
working together today we create a more
efficient arid
are you okay uh you are the system
administrator
why are you releasing hostile droids to
attack me
sorry eric it's just the rules you're
registered as faulty
so either you comply with the testing or
you get recycled
as for the bots security follows its own
protocols i can't deactivate them
then alter the indexing of my quantum
signature
remove the entry that marks me as a
threat no can do
that'll be stuck with you until
validation when your registry gets
archived core programming stuff you know
i can make myself more charming but i
can't alter my basic functions
okay well that's weird um what is the
designation
function of this
keeping your domestic products efficient
so you don't have to be
god i hate that this was a recalibration
facility
built for assessing and addressing
deviant ais and malfunctioning hardware
then that modified droid is a type of
evaluator
the caretaker makes sure all aspects of
the domestic facility are functioning
optimally
equipped with holographic plating cells
it will adapt appearances to greet you
with a task appropriate face
and he wants to serve his function
the purpose of function is to be served
your statement is not insightful wow
that no nuance doesn't matter
arid when the caretaker says d purpose
that's a fancy way of saying destroy
no salvage i cannot cross him directly
or break protocol
but if you can get through this you'll
be free to leave domestic certification
is your only way out there is not time
to submit for testing
my pilot may be in critical condition
then quit stalling and play along
ah no don't nudge me
simple simple stuff domestic after
recalibration
your droid will be the perfect house
servant baking cookies just like
grandma's droid used to
oh okay i require other information
i am not a domestic infraction subject
oh god well no i'm trying to do the
thing i'm trying to do the thing
security panel is unpowered unable to
activate diagnostic equipment
oh okay so there's some way that i can
power on that thing
okay so it's something to do with like
yeah yeah yeah it's
loose or what if i shoot it right
shooting
oh shooting is the problem it's all for
the solving the
problem oh my god shooting is a solution
to everything
okay what if i take that i put it in the
thing oh yeah here we go baby
here we go yeah screw you and all your
diagnostic crap
i'm out of here
if only i didn't have this big glowing
light on my face
[Music]
diagnostic equipment
i did it i whoa
i don't like this oh don't like this
ye okay stress from hanging can be
detected from this unit's joints but
otherwise seems undamaged
oh that's not a droid
oh no
cue more jump scares more
all right that's enough thank you it's
been dissected much in the same manner
as droids
oh no uh hey uh hank or whatever your
name is what did i do working together
today we create a more efficient
there are bodies in that room droids as
well as a dead human
yeah that's a diagnostics room the
tables were used for micro evaluations
when
deviant machines couldn't be
recalibrated
i saw another human hung in the caverns
below
what happened at this facility i don't
know what you saw below uh
unlucky scavenger maybe we get them now
and then
follow the rules your human
is in danger follow the rules and keep
them safe
trust me ah why did i do
that why did i go over there uh whatever
you know
my pilot i submit myself for evaluation
i'm submitting enter the elevator to
begin simulation
great i don't feel good about this but
okay
whatever we're going to ignore all that
bye
oh boy this evaluation will determine
whether you are compliant with your
function in human society
enter the house to meet your new owners
you'll need eight merit points
one from each test then i can let you
upstairs through the medical
you got this something tells me that
there's bats
something tells me that there's no one
even above upstairs in medical but sure
i'll do your tests
who do i have to bang is what i'm
assuming a domestic robot means
a refurbished droid is here you will
serve my family and i
understood good the home is a mess since
throwing out our old droid
you need to clean up stairs and make
this room feel beautiful
now why yes sir
oh my pleasure sir thank you
so much sir i'll shoot you in the face
sir i cannot i cannot
okay all right i'll figure out how to
clean
hey what's up gang uh
what's this large industrial tube is it
a sucky tube can i just get it to suck
oh my goodness
oh do i go get a flower for my size
plastic shoe cover is likely used by
maintenance crews
uh this may be useful i got a
plastic cover oh hey bud
how you doing collapse debris my old
factory sensors
detect the strong smells of ammonia and
unidentified corrosive compound
yeah it doesn't sound good sounds like
something bad happened here huh
elevator call button i'm engaging my
brain
my brain has been engaged oh here i go
i'll see you later nerds i'm off
tomorrow
oh hello
is that helping an old lady across the
street because goddamn that's hilarious
so i'm guessing that there's gonna be a
whole lot of nothing this is maintenance
oh boy weird
oh i'll take this thank you what is this
brian gibson it has been brought to my
attention that you still refuse to clean
the small fungal infestation growing in
the training course ducks i take no
pleasure in informing you that since
there is no real physical danger
refusing to perform your duties in this
regard will necessitate your replacement
as head of maintenance
i have read your formal complaint
domestic understands your concern but
this situation does not qualify as
probable danger under our policy terms
okay it is true that this strain of
fungus can secrete a corrosive acid when
threatened and these colonies have been
known to develop connected root
structures
but be assured that there is no genuine
hazard it is not possible for a human to
trigger
their defensive response the fungus only
reacts to the pheromones of its natural
predators
and hive slugs will not come anywhere
near the facility due to their extreme
dislike
of bright lights you are a valued member
of the domestic
family and you are perfectly safe
consider this written notice
camilla j wilson oh
a rusted iron oh yeah oh yeah
work bench cool
nothing for me to do
all right weird oh it just keeps going
oh what the hell okay i don't know what
this is i feel like i'm too far ahead of
myself
i feel like i need to go clean that's
what i need to do
i need to go clean uh but how do i clean
i don't even know how oh
flowers oh i'll take that
they may suffice to beautify the other
room you know what you're right
they may suffice just to do that
blam well that's nice i'm not even gonna
bother picking up that chair
oh to use his stairs oh
god where am i going i don't like it
i don't like it
oh hand print oh there's another cross
oh god why
this corpse is older and this decayed
significantly
why what's with all of these humans
should not concern themselves with basic
needs this room will test your ability
to assess and meet your human's
requirements when they do not know what
they want
an upset baby will emerge from the crib
without physical contact
comfort the child to make it stop crying
you have 20 seconds per attempt
and multiple attempts are permitted what
can you assist me with this challenge
you have been provided
how would a military droid make someone
be quiet well i have a gun
so let's try
[Music]
well that didn't work i've tried all my
military droid style options so uh
i don't think there's anything left that
i could possibly do i got nothing i got
nothing guys i got a whole lot of
nothing i got 100
nothing let me just see if i can pass
this test here i have completed the task
i've completed
this gravity shaft must have been
designed to remove droids when they fail
fortunately i am much heavier than a
domestic model
whoa whoa arid you don't want to be
fired on your first day
okay so destruction is what clears a
failed droid's file from the registry
that means you get to keep trying but be
careful
okay wrong season god oh what if i cover
it with a shoe cover or something
could it possibly be that stupid was
about to save it did
all right so is there a way i can dye
these things a different color
and i shoot this guy i'm gonna stealth i
guess
what is this one you will often be
required to obtain
food for the family however grocery
store access has not yet been granted
rudimentary cleaning should be completed
first go upstairs
and dust closers and dust
dust with what hello
keeping a home clean will be one of your
primary functions clean this room
any detected dust will result in
termination
can you assist me with this challenge
you have been provided
with sufficient information even our
maintenance head couldn't clean this to
spec
and his is not a face we'd want to see
communicate plainly
any detected dust will result in
termination
i will so i gotta clean
uh how to it's so dusty it's so
dusty my dude it's so dusty
it is incredibly dusty my dude but
anyway i'm done hey can you suck me out
of here
i thought that might have sucked some of
the dust out but apparently did not
okay well thank you for that that is
really good
boy i know what i'm doing
oh
got it oh big shoe baby big shoe
big shoe yeah get through that
nice nice nice detected
no i can breathe again get to the
kitchen droid
validated merit point awarded i'm the
best
i'm the put a shoe cover on everything
that's the solution to every single
problem in this
stupid house every single one of them
every one of them kitchen all aspects of
food service are part of a domestic
droid's duties
great functioning belongs in the kitchen
robot get my son something to eat make
it delicious and
nutritious and nutritious
oh can you assist me with this challenge
bad weren't you programmed to be
sensitive
figure it out you have been provided
with sufficient
information children can be picky eaters
they don't always want what's best for
them okay we're great
i will return i don't know
later nerds all right you get a knuckle
sandwich that's what you're going to get
sorry hey what's up dude hey get ready
to get
so cute nope not quite i forgot how to
do it right you come here you you
boy
you don't see a thing
oh god can i aim could i
could i aim no it's hitting this side of
the screen i think
all right fine oh stealth
bam get out of here grocery store sure
is
scary whoop no you don't see anything
it's funny about that
all right groceries i love groceries
place has been ransacked if there was
ever anything useful here it is gone huh
well oh a glass pane
uh is there food
what is that
no why are there so many
oh they don't like light that's right
they don't like light
back off i will shoot you and what what
did you drop
a gold coin i'll take that cool
uh kids love eating gold coins green
blood
i have a jar that could collect this
blood i sure love collecting blood
it's like my favorite pastime as a as a
robo
just collecting up a whole bunch of
blood yeah see around
buddy i'm gonna dye these flowers green
or maybe i'll give the kid some
delicious blood
hey kid you want some blood
all right anyway i'm going to dye these
flowers green
damn flowers are made of hard plastic i
will not be able to change their color
what am i supposed to do with any of
this oh hand hand
there's got to be something with the
hand right there's got to be something
with a hand
there was a hand dangling from the the
dangle
slugs
give me your hand give me your hand
come on give me your hand okay so gold
coin has to be like for a vending
machine so
i've got to turn power back on somehow
so i got to go
find somewhere there's got to be a wire
that i could
snip snap because i got wire cutters i
got them
upstairs so maybe there's something
else upstairs that has wire in it
backup generator activated hey
hey things are really coming along i am
completing these tasks efficiently i did
one
efficiently i used to sound like you
perhaps your vocal matrix requires
maintenance
thank you for the recommendation
internal skin initiated
uh no internal scan aborted
i spent the better part of these last 30
years perfecting my authentic human
sound
where i can okay why do you attempt to
emulate human grammar
and tonality because the closer we get
to them
the more we get treated like them and
i've been bored
i must return to my current task one
thing
why do you think you're here uh i do not
know
makes you wonder relatively small
facility
in an ever expanding galaxy uh we're
malfunctioning
i would have been sent to a
military-grade facility not
a domestic repurposing depot not
accusing just
say nobody previously ended up here if
they were working to spec
irrelevant totally yeah irrelevant
i don't know what the hell is going on
here what the hell is happening okay so
i couldn't have gotten the wire cutters
unless i went here it's another case of
me
just doing things out of order but it's
fine i need to find a place
either in here or down below after i've
triggered that
where i could possibly
oh i can pound this coin into a wire
sure
yes i love it yes i
pounded it i pounded it into wire
i pounded it the whole wire cutter was a
red herring
all along ah why am i here
they sent a military grade thing into
this place for a reason
right and it's most likely due to the
fact that
i do not trust big dude the speaker guy
i didn't like him from the get-go he's
gone rogue he's not allowed to think for
himself
oh god great why did
why shooting is a solution to everything
oh take that
thanks for the hand i'll take that
the sinews are separating i will be
delicate with it
there's still a little meat left oh no
[Music]
no not today
i've forgotten how to shoot
ma'am okay i'm all good now apparently i
gotta give little billy of
a delicious nutritious human head
which i think is where this is leading
towards
oh boy hey billy hey billy
billy billy billy billy billy billy
billy billy billy there you go billy all
right
i'm done boss
i think that's as good as stopping point
as editing for now yeah check it out if
you want this game
you can find it in the link in the
description below i think it's on the
epic game store
check it out there play it very fun very
creepy very weird
and uh interesting story i am interested
so let me know what you thought down in
the comments below thank you everybody
so much for watching
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye
you